Moe moe boo!
Okoe moe moe booe
moe booe Hello Hello hello hello and say hello To Johnny
He's in my lap He's in my lap Hello Hi Johnny Hi Johnny
Incoming Do you have anything to say?
You?
Do you have anything to say?
Hold on let me take it.
Wait one second do you have anything to say he's yawning say
something say something
y 'all into johnny johnny mike he's mad because he gets fed
in three hours and i haven't fed him yo yo you're so upset
you're so upset
yeah get comfy get comfy little guy Johnny Mike he sounds
upset he's quite upset he's quite upset yeah Johnny is very
funny you know I've kind of started comparing him to can we
get a permanent Johnny Mike it might be a little tough for
me to set up But, I mean, I have it just kind of sitting
here.
Oh, Sinister, happy early birthday!
I don't know if I'll be streaming tomorrow or not yet.
I'm still planning out in my week, sorry.
But probably not.
Even though I took yesterday off.
Never got to these to 29 before.
Murphy, thank you!
Murphy Reel, Murphy Reel.
I introduced a new girlfriend to you and now...
Oh, there goes Johnny.
We're watching it together.
Hi, girlfriend.
Death Pigeon, thank you.
I hope you guys both have fun.
Johnny's kind of funny because I've been comparing him
recently to like an indie horror game.
In that, you know, in those simulation games where it's
like...
like you you are the you are the owner of a grocery store
today your task is just to mop the floors and then every day
it kind of like adds a new task that you have to like that
you have to watch out for on top of everything so it's like
tomorrow you'll have to mop the floors and uh and take out
the garbage content leach welcome to memboo ship thank you
and baby core thank you so much for the five gifted and then
day three it's like you have to mop the floors take out the
garbage and wash the dishes johnny is doing this every day
so one day he'll be like his obsession is going under the
couch day two his obsession will be going under the couch
and going into the three his obsession is going under the
couch going into the fridge and and what what is going into
the closet day four his obsession is going under the couch
going into the fridge going into the closet and hanging from
the blinds or from the from the curtains and i'm i mean i
just wanted to say thanks for being you i just moved across
the country for work and you being my osha has made things
brighter and less lonely yeah it's your night sorry you
can't watch all your streams new job and move it's nice of
him to give you a tutorial for taking care of him oh gosh
now actually his recent obsession is stalking me so i'm
being stalked one of his favorite things is like getting
chased and then chasing after me and then i chase him and
then he chases me but he like sometimes will like want to
totally stalk me and And so I'll like walk around the corner
and he'll be like, I'll see his ear, kind of like the shadow
of his ear waiting, waiting to get me.
Go Johnny, do your task.
Pay the rent.
Pay some rent.
Okay, we have confirmed one thing for certain.
Johnny is definitely a cat.
Was there any?
Was there any doubt?
your 3d birthday live from last year today i wanted to say
that i say i love that it's basically a halloween special
maddie thank you i really appreciate uh thank you thank you
i recently received your shirt oh gingerbread man thank you
yeah johnny is a cat big surprise sometimes cats are
secretly dogs okay that's very true johnny is quite dog like
but also very cat like i'll come out I'll walk out of like
my room and I see him on the kitchen table and he's not
supposed to be on there and he just goes he just looks at me
and goes
Johnny is a hybrid um I also want to say oh thank you um you
know I uh the stream if you're watching the VOD it might not
be any different but the stream itself is uh is um a day
late i took yesterday off um friday night i was i was
struggling avoiding a mental breakdown i was like hands face
in my hands like head in my hands being like oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god i at least he doesn't have
the same problems mgs johnny has well he is very smelly very
very stinky but that's a cat's job too right um yeah i was
not doing well so much on friday night um i had realized
that night that i had forgotten something pretty big and
then also i was given another thing that had an extremely
tight deadline and then i've been doing a lot of a lot of uh
prep and getting ready for other things getting ready for my
birthday and um it all kind of compounded on friday night so
i was like oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh um but hopefully
everything works out and i did i i did um you know i had
vexbo which was a lot a lot of fun um if you went thank you
so much um and also it's past your bedtime but uh it was a
lot of fun so I did have that but for the most part I just I
kind of worked on some stuff that I was neglecting a little
bit and of course the thing that the big thing that I had
forgotten so um yeah I yeah I'm so sorry I'm so sorry never
be afraid to take time off of your for your mental we love
you over here for you till the end no matter what scuba
gator thank you thank you i i you know um even usually when
i have a lot of stuff going on i'm able to kind of like i
think it was the fact that i had forgotten a really big
thing and it kind of just sent me spiraling and usually i'm
pretty good about like being like okay we can handle this we
can do this but i was like little bells
but yeah um it's all good it's all good and my birthday is
in uh is is in soon is in soon oh i'm excited i'm so excited
i'm gonna be 19 again you guys and that's so cool what did
you get for snack shimmyki i got she popcorn there's a bag
of popcorn i've been trying to get through so and i forgot i
was working up until stream so i forgot to eat because i was
working hi aminto did you know that every third sunday in
september is national wife appreciation day every third
sunday in september there's only one third sunday so
wouldn't it be the third sunday of september
Or is there more than one third Sunday in September?
Yeah, but every year.
Just want to make sure you know.
I appreciate you today.
Thanks, Gopal.
Thank you.
Wait.
Do you know what tomorrow is the 21st of September?
Do you remember?
I'm kind of sad.
I've been, like, taking Mondays off.
Because I, if I don't, Mondays tend to be the days where
it's like, there's not a collab.
Like, people don't ask for collabs.
There's not, like, a lot going on.
I've always not liked taking Mondays off because I kind of
want to have, like, a stream at the beginning of the week.
I might start doing, I might switch it to Tuesdays.
But I was like, oh, man, I took a Monday off because...
But I don't know.
Maybe I will stream tomorrow.
Do you remember?
It's already the 21st for me.
But it's not 21st night.
It's not 21st night.
Mm-hmm.
First day of fall.
No, that's...
Oh, sorry.
I was watching TikToks.
That's Wednesday.
Wednesday, the 23rd, is the first day of fall, right?
Wait, where to go?
Wait, am I right?
No, that's the 6th.
Yeah, Autumn Equinox.
Vod gang, today have fun.
Thank you, Ron!
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, that's 22nd.
Then why does it say...
Why does it say Autumn Equinox 23rd?
On my calendar.
When is autumn?
Huh?
It says I have no internet on my...
When is autumn?
What the...
What do you mean to...
What?
I'm not going to an address.
Google.com.
What?
Dock, dock, go.
What do you mean to...
address not found.
What is this stupid thing?
Huh?
I feel like I'm getting gaslit.
There we go.
Thanks for the five gated.
Oh, did I get raided?
Ah, hi.
Ducky, thank you for the gated.
Wait.
Google says it's Tuesday for, yeah, but that's AI that
always lies.
There's this guy on TikTok that I think is so funny.
His name is Husk.
And he always like talks to his chat GPT.
And one of them recently was like, how many, how many E's
are in 17?
And he was like, and the chat GPT was like, three E's.
And he's like, no, there's four E's.
And chat GPT is like, no, there's three E's.
and he's like he's like if if i'm right well you say that
i'm smarter than you and chachi piti is like well i'll say
that you're right he's so sassy and then he counts he's like
okay count him and he goes s e that's one v e that's two n t
e that's three another e that's also three
That's still three E's.
It's the first, the second, the third, and another third.
The doubling down.
It's so funny.
E counts as one.
Yeah, exactly.
Vince, you don't have to apologize.
Your health is always important.
Thank you for everything you have done to make everyone
here.
Have a great time.
Oh, Blue Cherry, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I really, really appreciate it.
I'm feeling much better now, though.
But thank you, everybody, with your well wishes and
everything.
Sorry to worry.
Almanac says 22nd.
What?
Ommanac.
Why does my calendar...
You guys...
You guys, I swear it says...
It says Wednesday 23rd for me.
Oh, wait.
Holidays in Japan.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Eh?
Oh.
If
I had planned something for the 23rd being like, it's
autumn!
And everyone's like, shut up.
Dummy, you missed it.
Wednesday is the first full day of autumn, but autumn starts
on Tuesday evening.
Does that explain why I have respect for the age day on my
calendar?
I always wondered what that was.
Wait, that's tomorrow.
No, wait, I'm sorry.
It's today in Japan.
Halloween too.
I'm currently playing Elden Ring while watching Over Sucker
Water.
I also recently got a new job offer that I accepted.
Joshua!
Congratulations!
I also have Bridge Public Holiday.
What other holidays do we have in Japan?
What the heck is this?
How did I get Japanese holidays on my calendar?
I never knew it.
I never knew.
Oh, you know what probably should have given it away was
Emperor's birthday.
We get respect one day a year.
That's it, buddy.
Don't be greedy.
Best excuse for missing things Japanese calendar.
giving 10 bucks as respect for the age.
Hey!
She moved to Japan, but forgot about it.
Oh, baby, right.
Just got home from Mexico!
Thanks for-
Oh my gosh, burnout.
Thank you so much for the- For the- for the- for the- For
the- for the- For the- Thank you so, so much.
Wait, who rated me earlier?
I didn't even get to say hello.
I didn't even get to say hi.
Mm-hmm.
Nice gifts.
Yeah, thank you everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Bernal.
Hmm.
The most Minto mistake to ever make.
I can't believe it!
Oh my god.
But also, why is my internet, my...
Why is it all working?
Oh my gosh.
Uh, let me just Google something.
Monkey butt.
Oh, wow.
address not found why is it not working is waterfox down or
something what's happening whatever i'm not i'm not
searching things on google today i'm playing a game
currently playing the jukebox in control good luck if you
try it today whoa thank you mcmack wait why why good luck is
it scary just reincarnated japanese princess things yeah
yeah exactly Does the internet think it's in Japan too?
It could, it could.
Jukebox is a challenge.
Well, you know, I'm not looking to 100% the game or
anything.
You know, there will be some side quests we don't get to.
That's okay, that's okay.
No worries, no worries.
Yeah.
You start watching the recordings of me playing Alan Wake.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
game was a bit of a I like it I don't get me wrong I really
enjoyed it I'm gonna say something controversial though I
like deadly premonition if we're talking about games that
take place in the same region and our twin peaks adjacent
I'm going to say that I like deadly premonition more no me
though the book is called water ship down what does that
mean why are the bots so strange
Speak your truth.
I am.
I'll say it.
I think we all do here.
Hey, Minta, I hope you're feeling better.
Thank you so much for coming to Expo this year.
I did a cosplay of you, and there must be something in that
outfit which makes the person feel extra cute.
It should.
Lorna, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
you have any pictures that I'd love for you to post them so
I can see unless I already saw Alan wink ain't no Francis
York Morgan it's so true you hear that Zack she likes us
more oh I was talking to a friend about deadly premonition
and she was like did you watch twin peaks and I was like no
not yet and she was like oh wait so you played deadly
premonition but how much of the game was ripped from Twin
Peaks.
So I really, I was like, but I got to have like a true, you
know, if something I've seen in Twin Peaks, if I play Deadly
Premonition and I see it, then I'm going to be like, oh,
that's Twin Peaks.
But now I got like a true like, surprise.
I don't know anything that's going to happen.
We have to do a watch along.
I really do want to do a watch along.
Wait, I wish I could Google stuff.
How many episodes?
How many episodes is Twin Peaks?
Oh, sorry.
Check the address.
I'm not looking up an address.
I'm on DuckDuckGo.
Stop it.
Why is my phone being weird?
I don't know.
I can't Google literally anything right now.
So strange.
Three seasons and a movie.
Okay, community.
Wait, is it actually three seasons in a movie?
Control never played that game.
It's a lot of fun.
It's really a lot of fun.
Wait.
How many seasons is Twin Peaks?
But the movie is before season three.
Got it.
Are they those episodes that are like...
That are like...
An hour long.
Mint Fumo enjoyed Moshi Expo.
Oh, Liberator Axia, thank you!
I'm glad.
Also, Mint Reel enjoyed Moshi Expo.
Two original seasons plus retro revival.
Ho, ho, ho, ho.
First season is just a few episodes and a half.
The second season can be skipped.
No, I would not skip.
I don't want to skip.
Around 45 minutes just TV link.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's not bad at all.
Though that will take a bit to...
That will take a bit to get through.
Oh.
Ugh.
You've been doing so many cons recently.
Happy.
You're enjoying them.
Yeah!
Unfortunately, though, I think...
There might be one more con, but Vexpo might have been the
last this year for me, I think.
Whoa, I think maybe.
I think maybe, I think maybe.
A lot of people skip a chunk of season two on rewatches for
reasons.
Oh, on rewatches, I think that's understandable.
but if you're like wanting to watch a series for the first
time then I think you should watch the whole thing right
even if it's just even if it's just you know
yeah for the like you know on rewatches I get it yeah but
what about holiday Matsuri I don't think so this year um
Unless, like, not as a guest itself, you know.
Fun fact, Deadly Permanation and Alan Wake came out on the
same year, 2010.
No way.
That's crazy.
Me too.
That's me.
But yeah.
Hmm.
But, yeah, I think.
No more conventions the rest of the year.
that's crazy but i still but but but but but i do still have
stuff coming up so so don't think that it's gonna be just
cruising until the end of the year i mean it's only it's
only the end of september we have we have so many more
months left until the end of the year so there's still more
things just not not convention things so i mean my birthday
is coming up I can I be selfish I want to see one of those
you guys know those those those those Twitter like little
banner things that say like it's I'm celebrating Mito's
birthday I want to see one of those made I want to see lots
of people have them I always think they're so cute they're
so cute Maybe I could see if I could get one made or
something.
Yeah, the profile picture frame.
Yeah.
But I already have plans for birthday.
So, you should.
Also, get excited.
New merch?
Well, like, honestly, i i said that i wanted to slow down on
merch a lot so i said one thing i said one thing though the
new outfit merch should be also on pre-order starting
birthday and then one one thing for birthday yes
And the one thing I asked for it to be pre-made so that
things can get shipped out near immediately because I was
like, you know, I want people to have this for October.
One thing, but it's a car.
Everybody get the Minto Mobile.
so um you know you already seen you've already seen the uh
the new outfit merch i've already talked about that one but
a good one the one thing for my birthday i think is pretty
cool it's a little it's quite different style from what a
lot of stuff i've put out before so um yeah uh think is
pretty neat and if you thought that things have been a
little bit too cute in the past then this may be more up
your alley hmm okay that's enough hints though that's enough
hints that's enough hints yeah it's gonna be a convertible I
partnered with I partnered with BMWs for a mint car
Edgy minto?
It's still kind of cute, though.
But also...
Also, the other way I would describe it is Matara.
That's the only other way that I feel like I know how to
describe it.
The recent BMW designs are quite ugly.
Oh, wait.
I think I know what you're talking about.
Didn't they like change the front of the car and it looks
ugly now?
What a description.
I know, I have to keep you guessing.
I have to keep you guessing and because I am scheming.
So it's a Volkswagen bug.
Oh yeah, why didn't I say that?
It's a bug.
it's a vintage bug full of bugs little little minto bugs
it's actually i don't imagine wait i just had an idea hold
on let me write this down i don't want to say it out loud
hold on where's my notes
you guys are probably like oh my god what kind of idea could
she have gotten from bugs us please spare us oh why why what
do you what do you mean um oh
oh oh my idea is growing wait i only have these kinds of
ideas in the shower excited for the ibu candies that you can
eat just like matara eats the mo-mo's yummy
Okay, I wrote it down.
Well, guys,
yeah, I've been streaming from the shower right now.
Wouldn't be the first time.
Yeah, this is a shower stream.
Everybody gets squeaky clean, squeaky clean.
Are we ready to take control?
No, we just got into, like, a really cool area.
So I'm excited.
to continue, to continue.
One second.
But I also don't hear Johnny, so I'm gonna go check up on
him real quick.
I'm nervous.
One second.
I must check, I didn't, cause he was in my lap, which means
he's not asleep.
Sometimes I don't check up on him because he's asleep.
And I don't need to.
One second.
Johnny, we're good.
Okay, Doki.
And let me eat some popcorn.
Popcorn.
I'm not...
I have to be a little nice with my voice today.
I've been doing a lot of...
practicing.
Where was he?
You a sunbathing.
Why'd she say it like that?
Can a ghost practice?
Okay.
Continue.
Oh, I just realized I've been in silence.
You guys have not been able to hear the game this entire
time.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel so silly.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
Why did nobody say anything?
I didn't realize, because I can hear it on my end.
Oopsie.
Alright guys, we are in the Panopticon.
We are in a containment.
My abilities?
I don't got much.
Wait I can upgrade now Spin has a generous Wait spin Shatter
is the shotgun This is the construct Charge is the Not the
sniper And then spin is my pistol right You mean the
Pentagon No Yes Charge is a new gun.
Oh good, grenade launcher.
Yes, yes, yes.
So if I upgrade my spin, that's pretty good.
Oh wait, spin is the new one.
Wait, then what is what?
Shatter is...
Wait.
Charge holds up to three explosives.
Wait, is Pierce then?
Wait, which one?
Pierce is the sniper.
Then where's my pistol?
The speed goes brrrr.
Grip is the normal one.
Is
it that I can't upgrade it until I construct these?
Must construct additional pylons.
Construct ones you don't have at all.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hmm.
Yeah, it scrolls, but I'll need to there.
No, it's not there.
It's not there.
It's tied to game progression.
progression.
Okay, okay.
I thought I got pierce.
Oh no, it says upgrade pierce.
That's why.
Okay, okay.
Is it unlock the second mod slot and increase base weapon
damage.
I haven't used it much because even though it is a sniper
type gun, I don't like the charge method, the charging for
it.
So we'll, we'll ignore them for now.
Wait.
Was there any mods?
I can upgrade this.
Oh wait, these were the...
Yeah, these are the ones that I can unlock for myself.
Is it worth trying?
Wonderful singing of expo.
Thank you, Vito.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna upgrade.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, construct a random weapon mod red.
Ooh.
What do I have for my personal mods?
I have pretty good ones, though.
Larker here, are you gonna play Control 2 this week after
you beat this game?
I love your Control streams, by the way.
Randomness, thank you!
Is it... Does it come out this week?
Wait, that's crazy.
Does it actually come out this week?
24th!
I don't think I can beat the game by then, though.
And I probably would want to beat Alan Wake 2 first, huh?
Oh, no!
The day after Autumn starts...
Hi.
Yeah, I think I should play Alan Wake too.
Wait, did I say Alan...
Wait,
is it...
Wait, Alan...
Wait, is it Alan Wick?
No.
No, it's Alan Wake!
Don't!
I thought you guys were laughing because I said Alan Wake!
I mean, Wick!
Oh my gosh, I thought you guys were like laughing because
you were like, ha-ha, she said it again.
What a dummy dumbhead.
Oh my gosh, you scared me.
Uncontrolling.
Okay, so we have a TV in here.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wrong gun.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh!
We're fine.
We have a TV in here that we have to subdue or whatever.
She's regressing.
No!
I just forget sometimes.
But also, you guys make me feel like I get the wrong one
sometimes.
I don't know.
Whatever.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Except that guy.
That guy's not fine.
Oh, wait.
The map is tab.
so there's something up top where we're headed to okay oh so
level one oh wow okay how many floors are there
my bad mink yeah one guide you you sure did personal oh wait
wait this seems maybe good you did but that's okay what do
we what do we have we have energy recovery speed launch
energy cost minus 20 i'm gonna replace this one but i still
want to keep the health remember alan climb you'll never
forget potentially potentially
what is this tell me everything give me the scoop on this
little guy here Or don't?
Oh.
What happened here?
Picnic basket.
No matter what you decide to do, I'll watch.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
It was great talking to you, Alexbo, even though I never
introduced myself.
I'm that guy that came with his mom.
Oh!
Varus, thank you!
Yes, yes!
I hope your mom had fun!
Yes, yes, yes.
Biggs are coming to see me too.
Is this a fan?
Oh, and it's running.
It is running.
But it's not doing like the...
You know.
Not going back and forth.
Alright, what else we got?
We have Thor's hammer.
Actually.
Oh my gosh, that's AI in my video game.
Oh, but the map shows.
I guess I can't go to the other...
It was blocked off, so...
Well, here we go.
Oh.
Altered items.
Units.
Marshall made it sound like it was on Dylan's fault.
Don't worry, it's contained.
These combat is so close it is!
I don't think she's telling me.
it on the second oh shoot where'd that guy come from hello
where did that guy come from oh i can't shoot it won't let
me oh that was kind of freaky whoa
that was kind of freaky that was pretty fun that was kind of
fun Oh, they were looking at me.
Oh, there's nothing here.
Oh, okay.
Hello?
Is anyone there?
Philip.
Oh, no.
Is it one of those things where you can't stop looking at
it?
Uh-oh.
Um.
Philip, hold on.
Uh, yep.
What's going on with you, buddy?
Oh.
Can you help me?
Damn.
He can't even blink.
I can't.
can't i'm sorry there's an emergency i'll come back i
promise okay okay just don't forget i can't stare at this
thing much longer oh no uh fine assist the agent after dylan
has been found okay we'll come back for you philip don't
worry i have it on my on my list of things to do you down
all right kind of funny that there's like a part a little
place here not much has happened in this area I heard
someone oh oh research personnel oh no bureau thing oh shoot
whoa shoot yeah don't worry I'll take them out I'll take
them out.
Where are they?
I got you?
There's one more, right?
Hi!
They're airborne!
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh, I don't got you.
If I could shoot, I would get you.
Here.
He's mine.
Don't shoot him.
He's one of mine.
Oh, are there no more?
I helped.
I'll help, I'll help.
Anything over here?
None.
Oh.
See ya.
He even gave us something.
That's cool.
Charge blast boost.
We're there.
We used to go down on the first floor too.
Am I just now noticing that I missed these?
Hello.
You are so welcome.
Where'd he go?
I got you.
I'm really good at my job.
I'm really glad you're enjoying the game in the game
universe.
Yay, Vicky.
Thank you, Melody.
I'm really enjoying the game.
Yes, yes, yes.
Was there anything down here?
That doesn't sound good.
Sounds evil, in fact.
Um...
Hmm.
What sounds so evil?
How's the audio?
Just...
Feel free to yell at me.
The heese.
Yeah, but where?
Maybe up there?
Sounds like he's right above me.
He is right above me.
Isn't he?
Sound is good?
Thank you, thank you.
All right, here we go.
Oh.
Oh, we saw this on the camera.
Oh, okay, there's more people.
Oh, nice.
Your streams are my fridge.
See, it's accelerator.
Nice.
I can't stop watching.
I need someone else.
I need backup.
Twisted passage.
That's the object of power.
The TV!
Okay.
TV time.
My show is on.
Whoa.
Oh, wow.
The Twilight Zone.
You know what show I've been watching recently?
Is Goosebumps.
I never actually watched Goosebumps before and so I was like
oh it might be fun to watch and those this show is no joke
the twists in it are so crazy I watched one recently whoa I
watched one recently that was like it was Halloween and this
girl was getting like tormented by these two kids I didn't
subdue it oh cleanse the Benikoff TV okay oh there we go um
there she she was getting tormented by these oh two two kids
and so uh she was just like but then like some other old
childhood friends of hers came back in town and they were
like we'll take care of those bullies she was like yeah my
childhood friends my friends they moved the way and now
they're back and so then they get like sent to it's
halloween and they're like go out trick-or-treating with the
bullies and we'll handle it from there do you think or else
died and alan wake know each other they have to yes attack
of the jack-o-lanterns oh my gosh you knew yeah and so um
they're like going trick-or-treating and then these two
jack-o-lantern head guys come up, which I thought was not.
They were like, look at these pumpkin heads.
And I was like, hey, that's what my dad called me.
they get set.
They were like, the pumpkin heads are like, we'll take you
to a neighborhood with better candy.
And they took them.
And then it showed that there were like four people that had
gone missing.
And those four people were in this town handing out the
candy.
And They were like, oh my god, we gotta get out of here.
And so they leave.
And the girl the whole time was like, are you my friends?
And then eventually they're like, ha ha ha, we were your
friends the whole time.
And she was like, oh my gosh, why didn't you say anything?
And she had another friend who didn't know the two people
that were out of town.
And he was like, how did you transform into pumpkin heads?
And they were like, ha ha, because on Halloween, you can be
anyone.
And then they take off their heads and they were aliens.
And they were like, the kid was like, whoa.
And the girl was like, didn't I tell you?
My friends from out of town are aliens.
And then the aliens, they're like, okay, we gotta go home
now.
Or we gotta leave.
But we'll be back next year.
And then, this is what made me go the episode.
I was like, holy cow.
Was because the aliens were like, hey, we gave you a lot of
candy tonight.
But don't eat all that candy.
You might get fat.
And also, oh, oh yeah, because she offered some candy.
She was like, she was like, do you want some candy?
And they were like, no.
But if you know any delicious adults, we would like to eat
them instead.
And she was like, you eat humans?
And they were like, yeah, that's our diet, humans.
And she was like, so the four missing people, and they were
like, and then they go, by the way, don't eat all that candy
because you might get fat and we'll be back next year.
What?
You might eat your friend?
Oh my god!
I thought it was pretty crazy.
Wait, how do I get up here?
It's so dark, I can't see anything.
I'm going in blind.
Probably not the best thing to do.
Yeah!
Isn't that crazy?
Hello?
How do I get up there, actually?
Was there a staircase here?
Oh.
Yeah.
I am P. Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you for the...
For the raid!
Hello, deadbeats!
Wait, have you guys ever played control before?
We're a little... We're a little far in.
This might be spoilers.
Hi!
Thank you, thank you!
Good.
Welcome in, welcome in.
Sorry, I was just talking.
I was just explaining how I've been watching Goosebumps
lately.
Whoa, wait, I just noticed this room is cool.
Whoa.
Look at this imagery, great, whoa.
This looks so awesome.
Thank you for all the gifted!
Thank you, thank you!
Um...
What's up, Mint?
Hi!
We're playing...
Basically, if you don't know what control is about, you
join, you somehow become the director of a government agency
that essentially works with SCPs.
So it's pretty crazy.
What the... wait...
Okay, something...
Something has...
I'm seeing... Oh no.
Oh red means scary.
Oh!
Oh man.
And we have powers too.
Like this.
Bad example.
That's awkward.
One second.
Let me try again.
What?
Oh.
Don't
worry about it.
Can I shoot them?
Oh, jeez.
Ah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, shoot.
You are.
I should have added you to my friends list.
Ah!
Oh, gosh.
Don't jump up.
Ah!
Is that you?
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
I need health.
Oh, I think we got him.
Kind of?
Hey.
Hey!
I can wallolo!
Wallolo!
I should have wallolo load.
Wait, I can wallolo you.
Wallolo!
Wait, wallolo, wallolo, wallolo!
Everything's fine?
Holy shoot.
Oh, wallolo!
Wallolo!
Woollolo!
Okay.
Grab health.
Uh, we're fine.
Yeah!
My friend!
Holy cow!
Oh no no no no!
Yeah!
The
thing was Salvador, the head of security, Yeah!
This team didn't stand a chance against the hiss.
No one here does.
Nice shield, Minto.
Thank you.
That was close.
That was scary.
Well, there was Salvador.
Oh, please drop a cheesy one-liner for your victory speech.
That guy was fun, but it's time to change the channel.
What is this?
Okay, the TV.
One second.
Another object of power going nuts.
The crew of the white Ocelot!
Ah!
First encountered a strange spherical phenomenon while
fishing in the Redacted.
Witnesses described it as a black sphere with faint light
behind it.
It hovered just off the bow of the ship.
the crew redacted by throwing a tin bucket which disappeared
into the sphere.
ROW!
Soon after, the vessel lost structural integrity.
The ship's metal rusted and fell apart within minutes.
As the ship sank, the sphere lowered into the water.
A passing fishing vessel called the redacted rescued the
four surviving crew.
TV appropriate plus two.
That was pretty good, right?
agents were dispatched to the white Ocelot's last known
coordinates, redacted, and began diving operations.
On the ocean floor, the agents found the sphere.
The ship was entirely destroyed except for its anchor.
As agents lifted the anchor off the ocean floor, they
noticed the sphere behaved in conjunction with the anchor,
moving and stopping as one.
Contact with the sphere was avoided, but handling the anchor
proved harmless.
The item was transported to the redacted, by the redacted,
to the U.S.
port of redacted.
Upon arriving in New York, Awesome.
Here we go again.
Yo, yo, yo, one second.
Yoink!
Oh, my weapons mod is full.
Oh, oh, oh, let's deconstruct.
This is...
The one I'm using is damage 31.
We'll get rid of some twos.
Right?
It should be fine.
All right, all right, let's let's do it now.
Oh, this is all red.
Have you watched the movie this year?
I haven't.
I don't think so.
Use the TV babysitter.
Levitate.
Superhero over the obstacle.
I can levitate!
Oh.
Whoa!
Keep holding to levitate higher.
Oh, this is gonna change everything.
Is there fall damage?
Ouch.
Well, that explains that.
Yeah, now we can explore, explore.
Let's go.
These things, though.
La la la, excuse me.
Coming through...
Don't mind me.
I'm just making my way downtown while falling.
Wait, space while falling to slow fall safely controlling
the descent.
Oh,
oh, shoot.
Ouch.
Am I supposed to be fighting these guys?
Probably.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Ow!
Shoot!
Of course there's more of them.
Oh.
Maybe I was supposed to be kinda...
You know...
Uh... sneaky about it.
Well they don't see me.
Do they?
Oh they see me.
La la la!
Slowly falling!
That is not slowly falling.
I don't know what to tell them.
Can I fight while...
While levitating?
I want their health, but...
How am I supposed to do that?
How am I... I'm holding...
Shift sometimes.
I didn't do it there, but...
Can I... Oh, I can.
Oh.
How awkward.
Press it twice.
Oh, okay.
Are they going after me?
Holy cow.
Whoa.
Wait, I'm going to practice real quick because here I can
grab their health.
At least.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Okay.
And then hold.
No.
Oh, okay.
It is like a double tap.
Okay, got it.
Got it.
Yeah, you do have infinite bullets with the guns.
Newsflash.
The his static attempts to reach us.
Our broadcast must survive.
Doubt with the TV.
Now I can find Dylan.
Should I go down?
Yahoo!
Alrighty.
Ugh.
Whoa.
Nice!
It's so bright though.
Wait, now I understand how I'll be able to get some of the
things that I haven't been able to get before.
Am I gonna get ambushed in here?
Oh, oh boy.
Am I gonna get ambushed all right?
Oh, of course.
Oh my god, I can fly too now!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh, lo-lo!
Ouch.
Where am I even?
I can't see anything.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wo lo!
Wo lo lo!
Wo lo lo lo!
You think you're so special?
But, unfortunately, all the items still fall into the
ground.
Unfortunately, I can't fly for too long if I need to get
stuff.
Because everything still falls.
How did I get in here?
Yeah.
Watch your step.
Are the defense guys still out here?
Who are you?
Oh, hello.
I was just gonna get health.
Whoa, okay.
Okay, over there.
I think they left.
Cowards.
Okay.
Then we go this way?
Yeah, wide open area to fly in.
Holy cow.
Okay.
What the?
Oh, let me in.
Thank you.
Okay.
Cool!
A whole new...
Peek-up!
Oh, what'd you give?
Thank you.
Oh, sorry.
That's a swan.
What is this thing?
Won't somebody tell me?
What does it do?
What is a water...
Wait, is this the water...
Wait, didn't we read about a water cooler?
Is that sure?
Celebrity.
Oh.
Do you guys think this is a half-life reference?
Wait!
Is this a half-life reference?
Hey!
Where was our brother?
Now that I think about it, I cannot remember which cell he
was in.
Sorry, I forgot to check over here as well.
And, oh, there's a thing.
What the heck are you?
We got the Death Star in here?
Just kidding.
It's just a balloon.
I mean it's not just a balloon.
It quacks of course.
Change the objective.
Oh that's true right.
Uh, what was it?
Fourth floor!
Oh perfect.
Search my brother.
Yeah yeah.
Oh no he's on the fifth floor.
Okay just kidding.
Well we can still uh...
What was that?
What are you doing?
He's so close.
Oh, here's the set.
Wait, wait, I'm confused.
Am I stupid?
Search for him on the fifth floor.
Ah!
Okay, I get it.
I'm stupid.
Sorry.
I'm reading my reading comprehension.
Sorry I had to wake up so early this morning.
I'm doing my brother.
I've always wanted a brother.
I've always wanted a brother And you're mine
Things Many things I really wish they could Hello?
Can you hear me?
The Pope?
I really wish they would give me a flashlight sometimes.
I gotta get my material.
That don't look good.
Flashlight in the DLC.
Hello?
He's gone.
Dylan isn't here.
He might be nearby.
Or maybe the Hiss got to him.
I don't know.
We got his own stage and everything.
Dylan's here.
With us.
He just walked in.
He says he is giving himself up.
He's been affected by the Hiss, but he is different than the
others.
We must isolate him.
I'm on my way.
the hiss took his hair we need to get back the hiss took his
hair I have to see my brother oh my god oh how maybe I have
five I don't remember to be honest oh what's this about my
brother yes oh that's not what I thought there we go my eyes
yeah we gotta go save the fridge guy we will 930 this is
Dylan Faden's daily observations 930 breakfast is brought
1145 a.m.
gets out of bed uses toilet returns to bed what is this guy
complaining about you get out of bed at noon 1157 asks for
television to be turned on staff do so 12 p.m.
lunch is brought breakfast is removed 1202 eats lunch 238
uses toilet 403 begins talking to self recording speech is
not possible due to noise from television 407 becomes upset
throws lunch tray at glass he does this every day by the way
409 sedated crew clean the cell television is turned off 650
sorry 612 comes to asks for television to be turned on staff
Refuse?
616 sleeps, question mark.
Television privileges were refused due to hostile behavior.
Hisho!
It's pretty spooky in here.
Is there anything in here for me to like...
Down there, maybe?
For me to...
I guess we'll go down.
Anything?
My brother.
This is his room.
You're so funny, Minto.
Please don't succumb to the hiss and go bald.
I...
I can't believe they took his hair.
I can't believe it.
What diabolical, horrible creatures.
I won't take up too much of your time today, Dylan.
Like I said, I want to talk about Jesse, your sister.
Yes!
What about her?
I just want to get your perspective.
What do you think of her?
uh-oh is he gonna hate us i adored my sister when i was
little i mean back in ordinary and do you don't anymore when
i first got here sure i'd always hope she'd come too to find
me if you take me home we went everywhere together why
should this be any different casper said she could come to
to the bureau if she wanted to but she never did why do you
think that is But because she didn't care about it.
She always wanted to be out on her own, seeing the world.
She always said so.
Guess she got you the one.
No.
Right.
So she wanted to see the world.
Did she ever mention any place in particular?
Why?
We like to ask questions around here.
Do you know that?
Any particular cities, towns, landmarks, anything like that?
I don't remember.
No.
What about family and friends?
Were you friends?
Close with anyone living outside of Ordinary?
I'm done with this.
Tell Casper I want pizza for lunch.
Dylan, wait.
Tell Casper.
I'm not answering any more questions until I get my gummy
bears.
Wait, no, there's no way he actually thought that.
No.
That...
because that sounds so silly she could have come if she
wanted to oh yeah you know oh she I thought she would find
me oh yeah let me just find this actual hidden building in
New York City totally reasonable Dylan
that family trauma is going to cost a double pit I guess
that's the only thing in here seems like it alright let's go
Oh, oh, oh, there we go.
All right, let's go help our buddy on the fourth floor.
He did real good.
Yeah, just go to the super ultimate mega top secret building
in New York City that nobody can find ever.
To be fair, he was like eight.
Okay, that's, you know.
That's fair, that's fair.
So we search the P6L.
We have not gone to whatever that mystery thing is, I think,
over that side.
Is that the...
Is that the mysterious floor?
Uh, mysterious...
Maybe?
For now, we go back to floor four.
Oh, I did not mean to.
There we go.
Casper, I want Dino Nuggies!
And I won't settle for anything less.
Oh yeah, that was the balloon.
Could we make it over there?
Hold on.
No, it's sealed off.
Okay, so let's...
How far can we...
How far can we go?
There we go.
Oh, oops.
Oh, shoot.
I'm still getting used to it.
For some reason, I want to press control, like, Minecraft.
to this end.
We're fine.
Remote thought.
Well, this is still the... Okay, hold on.
No!
I'm screwing it up, you guys!
Okay.
Here we go.
Go up.
Shoot.
Now I'm at floor three.
I keep messing get up.
How do I get home?
They've given me the toughest task.
I can't... Well, let me go up, but only so far, right?
So it's kind of like...
Okay, we'll have to...
We'll have to go the long ways.
But what's over here?
I don't think I've been over here.
Oh, yeah, Cowabunga!
there's a height limit okay nothing here nothing here
secrets yeah you keep your secrets fbc we're going to fridge
guy we're going to fridge guy i've not forgotten them
sometimes it's just a little tough okay
i'm struggling whoa wait it's those cubes
Where?
I'm running.
Oh, shoot.
There's a lot of them.
It's okay.
I can also fly.
Yeah.
Oh.
Are you healing?
Oh my gosh.
Get out of my face!
Yeah, we got one of them.
Ah!
Wait, can I...
Can I add you as my friend?
No?
You're too good for me?
Wait, who's here still?
Someone below?
Oh my gosh.
You're too good for me?
Oh lo lo lo lo lo lo lo lo.
Friend request denied.
I want to grab these.
Oh, because I want to sell them.
Is it...
Wait, is it personal load?
Personal mods, yeah.
I think we just gotta start getting rid of the twos also.
Even though I'm...
Well, no, I'm not using a two.
We're too powerful.
We're too good for two.
We're too good, we're too good.
Who is that?
Oh, my friend.
Sorry, you sounded like a little evil for a second.
You sounded kind of freaky.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Let's go through the weapon ones as well.
Sorry, I always open the wrong thing.
I'll just get rid of all of them.
Same thing.
We'll give ourselves lots of...
Nice.
Too good, some might say.
Okay, we're on the fourth floor.
Philip, I'm getting distracted.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, this is where I came from.
Just kidding.
Philip, I'm not getting distracted.
I've been aware the entire time.
I'm totally...
I'm in control.
Hey boss, how's it going?
I'm having a great time.
How's it going?
Feel it.
Keep it.
Hey, what can I do?
Yep.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
If I look away, I don't know what this thing will do.
You have to get me out of here.
the door can only be opened by the pan opting on supervisor
that's Langston if he's still around looks like he has to
pee yeah I know him I'll go ask him how to get you out
please hurry my eyes they can't hey calm down just focus
what's your name you told you Philip focus right my name is
Philip and I think I can all on for a bit it's just my eyes
my eyes are so much just hang on philip poor guy for real
you'd think they'd like give them some glasses that like
some some hydrating you know like goggles you know like did
you guys ever fill your swim goggles with the water of the
pool i don't know why i would do that it's a terrible idea
oh wait there's There's a elevator, no?
Can I go down it?
If you fly to a room in the far left of the Swan, there's a
really cool Easter egg.
P6 room!
Okay.
I did feel like I missed some stuff, right?
Oh, shoot.
There's a height limit.
That's right.
How did I get...
Oh, through there.
I did feel like I missed some stuff, though, you know?
Okay.
Right here.
Run around, through the swan, left of the swan.
Where was the swan?
Oh, it's swan.
And then we'll help Philip.
That was the room I was trying to get to before, no?
And then I messed it all up.
Like the big bozo that I am.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I did it again.
Guys.
Oh.
We're back to our floor three!
Okay.
Why would they call it cell P6 if it's on the fifth floor?
I'm just gonna say it.
I'm gonna say it.
You're flying, you're flying, and Philip is dying!
He's not dying.
He just has extreme dry eye and don't get it twisted.
All right.
Wait, was this... Nope.
This was the wrong way.
Wait, I don't even... Can I go in there?
It's locked.
I don't even know if I can get in here.
Whoa.
I can't.
It's the room after that.
Wait, what do you mean the room after that?
It's locked.
One more on my right.
Oh, I see, I see.
Hidden location discovered!
Oh, it gave me a little achievement for it.
Very cool.
We found it.
Thank you, guys.
Nothing here.
Ah!
Here,
they're all the same.
It's a hideous trap.
Every thought might be real.
Fear, desire.
How can I ever know for sure I've escaped and not just lost
in my own fantasy of it?
That thought alone can drive you insane.
Oh!
Oh, Mr. Rake, you're so close.
Typewriter page.
Typewritten page.
A standard letter-sized typewritten page with minor water
damage.
The page is full of text, but apart from the top seven
lines, all the rest has been violently scratched out.
Only a few individual words and phrases can be made out.
Darling, looks different.
The page emits a dim glow in the dark when the text is read.
as if witnessing the page being written as he read it and as
if reality all around he was being redacted to match the
words of the page this feeling is made stronger if the text
is redacted forensic and linguistic analysis confirmed that
the text has been written by alan wake with the same
typewriter as the earlier materials brought in bright balls
in 2010 hello mr wake Get nervous!
Yeah!
Alan Wake area.
That's so fun!
Okay, how do I get down from here?
Holy.
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
We made it.
Easy now.
Easy does it.
Ah!
What the?
What?
Why are you back?
You're just jealous!
Oh, okay.
Everything's fine.
Did you see that?
So sick.
Okay.
Um, oh.
Well, great!
Great, great, great, great, great, great, great.
Where are you?
Show yourself.
You coward.
Where are you?
Oh.
So glad to see that reaction live.
I was late to the stream.
I'm afraid I'll miss it.
You didn't miss it!
There's another guy.
Too many guys.
I think maybe we're okay.
I want to see if I can go back down the elevator.
I'm coming back for you, Philip.
I'm coming back for you.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Yeah, they're mad because they didn't see Alan Wake.
They're so jealous.
They're so jealous that I got to see all the cool hidden
things.
Teleport?
Oh, well, we're just going back to this guy down here.
It's okay.
No, leave me alone.
Where was it?
Where was the guy?
Wait.
You think I can make it all the way over there?
Probably not.
Oh, wait.
There was a control point.
Oh, there's a control point right down there.
It's okay.
We'll teleport on the way back.
My bad.
I completely forgot.
That there was one right here, huh?
Oh shoot.
Yeah, I spooked you, huh?
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, yo, yo.
Yeah, I forgot this one existed.
Langston, this guy, he's so sad.
There's someone named Philip up in a cell.
He's watching a refrigerator and very rapidly losing it
hello Philip oh shit I forgot about fridge duty he's been in
there for over a day oh my god you forgot about him there's
a lot going on the hiss the Benikoff TV considering I'm
juggling ma'am I think listen it's fine we just need to get
him out of there he said you'd be able to open the cell door
yeah I can unlock it on my terminal there Wait, is that a
good idea?
But Philip can't just leave.
The fridge is behaving erratically.
Ocular contact is the only thing that seems to placate it.
If we don't have someone in there watching it 24-7, people
will die.
Well then switch off from like three people.
I'm pretty good with these things.
Being pretty good with altered items isn't standard bureau
procedure, ma'am.
He doesn't know us very well.
Yeah.
Um...
bye i'll see you later langston i'll be here like always
what if we put a mannequin in there with ultra realistic
eyes wait so now we should be able to go get him right
i struggle to upper panopticon upper panopticon where am i
philip
Philip, I went the wrong way.
Philip.
I'm back.
I'm coming in.
Thank you.
Thank you, Jesse.
The French is doing something.
Philip?
If I look away, if I look away, it hurts me.
Oh shoot.
Form.
This sounds like the board, but I can't understand.
Wait, is this a really...
Oh god.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Holy shoot!
Oh shoot!
Oh my god.
I
fell off the map.
Throw things into his eye.
You're so right.
I got so scared.
But also, what if it takes up...
What if it tears apart the world?
Yeah, let's try and throw the balls back at him.
Aw, man.
Oh, I feel bad for Philip.
Oh, wait.
The French is doing something!
Fail.
Incident in question occurred on Redacted and was brought to
HR department's attention by the internal security personnel
who intervened.
According to reports, supported by security camera footage,
Agent Filson entered the staff kitchen with the intention of
consuming his private meal.
A homemade sandwich cut diagonally and packed in a plastic
container.
Sinner sandwich.
but discovered the refrigerator had the refrigerator had
redacted his meal agent Philson began to kick the Bureau
owned appliance as he expressed his frustration in a loud
and profane manner this behavior caused multiple staff
members present to become alarmed security was alerted soon
after Philson complied with security's commands to desist
agent Philson was reprimanded and suspended for the
remainder of the ongoing work week the review committee.
It recommends one non-mandatory counseling session.
I would also hate my sandwich getting redacted.
Oh, there's blood.
Oh, why?
Why did you do this to him?
Is this a...
Is this a sign?
Like a foreshadowing?
I mean, those are the spooky month approaches I want to
recommend Still Wakes the Deeper look outside to be Spooky's
got nothing on your most excellent outfit.
Scalum, thank you!
Yeah, I actually was curious about Still Wakes the Deep.
Is it any good?
Alright.
We got this, guys.
Let's take down this.
It hurts me.
Warmer.
I wonder what power I'll get from this.
This sounds like a bird, right?
I can't understand it.
I'm ready.
Fuck.
Oh, yeah,
oh yeah.
Oh, hey.
Oh, yeah.
I keep falling off the freaking edge of the world.
Find the gap.
He's leaving holes when he slams.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's try one more time and then maybe it will let Philip,
you know, honestly, if we don't do this quest we let him
live oh oops you can flow okay i just got that power okay
if i look away it hurts for instant death pit blow right
right yeah all right let's do our best It's so hard to see
the floor.
Especially because I'm looking up at the stupid thing.
Like, he's so high up.
Oh, my energy is depleting.
Splat!
You...
Holy cow.
Yeah.
Whoa, we're so close!
That was close, though.
That was close, too.
Yeah!
Screw you!
There's no black pyramid here.
Yeah.
The fridge seems fixed.
Did fighting that thing off change something?
Oh, so that's kind of the idea about it.
Interesting.
Speak with Emily.
All right, cool.
So, uh, who?
Where?
Where was our brother?
Speak with Langston.
Well, let's go back, I guess, to there first.
Let's, uh, go talk to him.
Sorry, Philip.
Sorry I couldn't have done that sooner.
he said the same thing last time we go where's philip
philip's gone something happened before i could get him out
poor philip yeah it's your fault you never did like fridge
duty would anybody but if you're here then who's watching
the fridge the fridge was fine i took care of it you don't
just take care of altered items what did you do I touched it
and wound up in the astral plane.
This thing was in there.
It was huge.
Had one big eye.
Thank you for the read.
Hello.
Was it for me?
We've been getting reports from the astral knots lately
about something fitting that description.
The astral plane is usually connected to our world through
objects of power, not altered items.
Right.
If this thing is linking itself to altered items, then it's
clearly powerful.
This may happen again.
Do you think that thing is what got Philip?
Must have been.
Aw.
The Panopticon is a dangerous place.
The agents all know the risks.
But, since you're some sort of altered item whisperer, I've
got a list of others for you to corral.
I'm not your...
I'm not your janitor!
That's...
Here, start with these.
No!
See if there are any others missing while you're gone.
My life just got a whole lot easier.
I'm not doing this for you!
Get out of here.
I'll see you later, Langston.
No, we won't.
Like always.
My life just got a whole lot easier.
I'm not doing your dirty work.
Look how many abilities we have, though, now.
Look at
the final mod slot and increase the base damage.
Yay!
I finally got it.
Alter duty.
duty is so fun though is it you get powers for wait is it
like the last thing that we just said
no one respects the director yeah yeah i missed the part
without my problem
i got achievement for upgrading any item to three
Right, and abilities?
Let's see.
Oh, I can do it by levitate.
Whoa, wow, yes, sir.
Um, hmm.
Some of them are just fighting the former.
I'll think about it.
We won't do it right now, though.
What
was I trying to get?
Maybe more launch, more launch damage.
Always more health is good.
Hmm.
What was it?
What was shield?
Barrage.
Which we...
One of three.
Six.
Whoa, we could get shield barrage.
or was it oh shield rush we can't get that though that would
be all wait one three five seven ah
which one was this one oh my energy i only i mean maybe a
shield would be nice like better if i did have like you know
the barrage and everything multi-launch is my goal yeah mine
too energy now recovers while holding launch objects is also
kind of insane right let's just do this oh additional
personal thoughts let's go um
Okay, we save up.
Let's see.
Everything is exclusive.
Headshot damage.
Armor damage.
We'll do that one.
Probably not getting much headshots and not going a lot.
Energy launch cost.
What do I have for this one?
This is the energy launch cost.
Evade energy cost.
Shield strength plus 51%.
Hmm.
Actually max launch, multi launch before anything else I
didn't die.
Let's go.
I mean it already works so good.
Like I don't even see why you wouldn't to be honest.
Energy recovery speed.
We'll do that one.
Um, oh, uh, we're going to the boardroom.
We're going to Central Executive?
Yes.
Dylan, my brother!
Yeah, I do use Seas a bit, too.
When I can.
I think it's just fun.
I wonder, can you use Shield and Seas at the same time?
Hmm.
Levitate plus launch is amazing.
Can't get blocked.
Right?
The mission is emitted from the HRAs is purely antithetical
to every variant of the...
Hi!
No, it's happening.
After all these years, Dylan is here.
But am I too late?
How is he?
I need to know.
He's clearly been affected by the hiss, but it's different
than any other manifestation we've recorded.
is genetic we he was a prime candidate or maybe it's Polaris
protecting him something else affecting the situation I need
to run tests he seems more in control more present because
of the hiss I want to see him my brother or is he my brother
of course now Marshall set up an HRA warded cage to contain
him it's on the upper floor up the stairs okay I need to go
Jesse be careful I like Emily I hope she doesn't betray us
oh what is this she has to write everything in a made-up
gibberish code fucking martial arts series oh what is that
what a record on oh the jukebox oh no wait that was over
here wasn't it
Someone said this one was so tough though, no?
I'm here, I'm here.
Someone said this one was so tough, no?
Excuse me.
I found this token.
Any idea what it does?
She misses her Oni-chan.
Little bastards turn up in the weirdest places.
bad pennies the rangers use them to activate an old object
of power uh jukebox i assume that's what he said does it
have any good songs nope just the one record hey be careful
turning it on though when it's playing you get a free trip
to the formation the formation that sounds ominous the dog
why does it send you there it's meant to be done late you're
on i see i see years i mean it's just a pile of rocks built
by god knows who but while researchers have confirmed in the
same threshold as the quarry no one's ever been able to map
a physical route to the formation from maintenance so it's
in the quarry you just don't know where pretty much we only
send in annual expeditions to the formation now checkups
salvador calls them well salvador is uh come to think of it
the song should have rolled back hours ago i can go in and
take a look no we cannot appreciate that the jukebox is kept
just past the security booth over there Just put in a token
and enjoy the ride Interesting Doesn't I've been thinking Me
too Doesn't this guy kind of look like he's wearing A outfit
from Outer Wilds Stay sharp, fate How are you?
I'm not gonna do the jukebox Right now Actually, I am
Because I'm curious what happens I don't know if I won't I
mean I'll try obviously But if we die I'm not going to try
again.
Oh, it's open.
Play my song!
Oh.
Challenging expedition that grants rare chance.
Oh, rare rewards.
You get gear?
Wait.
I think I have to do the first one, though.
Player pierced damage.
Minus 75.
Yep.
What is the song?
Okay, let's try.
A jukebox challenge is like half an hour?
Oh.
Whoa.
It's cool looking in here, though.
Wow.
Can I leave?
You wouldn't have...
I guess they...
I was going to say you wouldn't have been able to do this
without levitate, but they did only kind of give it to you
after you got levitate.
so.
I guess that's fair.
Okay.
What?
Oh, shoot.
Woo!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh, oops, I think somebody was bot- oh, well, uh.
That was so fine.
Wow!
Anyway, let's go to Dylan.
I'm more curious about that.
You got blasted.
I know, right?
Oh no.
Guys.
Oh, abandoned.
Yep.
I don't care.
It's okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Let's go home.
Pizza's on me.
Yeah, let's go to...
Denny's.
Wait, can we actually go to Denny's?
That would be so awesome.
I understand now.
Those types of challenges, I mean, I'm not, I'm not, you
know, I'm fine with them.
They're just not my cup of tea.
Okay, she said upstairs, right?
On the upper level.
What does that mean?
Does she understand that this place is a literal maze?
Upper level could mean anything.
Wait, what's this?
promotion.
Dr. Darling has personally recommended Ms. Pope for a
promotion based on her work ethic and assistance in
advancing many ongoing research matters.
See Research Reports Redacted for breakthroughs resulting
from her work.
Don't forget to eat your daily mold vitamins!
Yeah!
According to her colleagues, Pope has displayed a keen eye
for detail on a quick grasp of paranatural concepts.
She is professional and diligent, though some of her
coworkers The review committee approves this recommendation
and promotes Ms. Pope to the position of research
specialists.
Have I...
How did I miss this room?
Was it just not open before?
There's no way.
I search everywhere.
Collective unconscious is defined as a form of the
unconscious that is shared in all human minds.
From the arises unconscious...
From this arises unconscious knowledge linking us through
our ancestral heritage.
through this collective unconscious we unknowingly attribute
a series of images and archetypes to all elements of our
lives these archetypes are never fixed but shift and change
in tandem with our species and culture this internal belief
in the power of images shared by a massive population is
redacted in the creation of altered items and objects of
power the sheer amount of redacted reducted exude is
attracted to the best representation of that image imbuing a
single Redacted.
I don't think I I didn't I did not Take in any of that
report Sometimes I can Like understand what they're trying
to Tell me.
I mean obviously I understand What a collective like
unconscious Is but sometimes I'm like Who?
That cat Ho Ho I don't know what I'm not even gonna pretend
to know
Are these all new rooms?
Hmm.
I need some action, goddammit.
I need some action!
Hmm.
What's this?
You like this song?
Me pretending to be busy at work?
I'm looking for stuff.
first off i find it harder to understand when i read things
aloud because i'm so focused on saying the words right me
too i'm the same exact way oh my brother oh he's oh no he's
talking his oh does so it's you happiness comes white pearls
but yellow and red in the eye through a mirror inverted his
name right leave your hands by the door push the finish
through the surface into the You've always been near you.
You walk us to patrol.
We stand around you while you train.
Hey, Dylan!
Hey, hey, snap out of it.
You're freaking me out.
Ew, he's saying his words.
Shit.
You are alarmed through time.
The thunder song distorts you.
That's Dylan.
Are we too late?
Can you hear me?
Oh, come on, Dylan.
I'm here.
I found you You've always been there Do you know who I am?
You know me Say it You are Dylan Faden's Sister He's talking
in the third person Always a good sign Do you know who you
are?
Not Dylan Trench and Darling made sure of that I I'm P6.
P6.
But I'm better now.
The hiss made me better.
Push the fingers through the surface into the wet.
You've always been the new you.
You want this to be true.
Yeah, you're freaking me out.
Stop that.
Not exactly the reunion I'd hoped for.
P6.
It feels good to say those words.
Like an itch.
I want to say them.
Ew, he's creepy.
They sound good they make me feel good don't you want to say
them too no fuck off no you need to help me get this thing
out of his head if he is still in there if there is anything
left you have to help me you you came in through the hole in
you we let you in you've always been here the only truth a
copy of a copy of a copy of a copy orange peel Orange peel!
You can see you.
This is not safe.
We found Polaris together with my sister.
When we were very small.
In ordinary.
In the desert, through the door opened up by the slide
projector.
Yeah.
But she didn't help when Trunch took me away.
We tried!
She didn't give me any powers.
Or apparently she did.
All the powers are my own powers.
And she didn't help when they locked me up for years.
After the song time for a pause, we build you till nothing
remains.
The egg cracks and the truth will emerge out of you.
Orange peel!
You are home!
The Bureau brought the slide projector back here with me.
Yeah.
And the Bureau did what the Bureau did.
does they used it and they found they opened the door up to
the hiss that's the only thing I can thank them for there
there it is we stopped the altered world event in ordinary
when we shut down the slide projector and now the projector
is here an earworm is a tune you can't stop humming in a
dream baby baby baby yeah baby baby yeah oh no he's humming
Justin Bieber is his earworm funny hilarious I welcomed the
hiss I let it in to get rid of her the hiss set me free
I mean...
You are a puppet.
I believe that.
You can almost hear our words, but you forget.
If we shut off the slide projector, maybe, maybe that will
stop the hiss.
Maybe it's not too late for my brother.
You must see the truth for yourself, Jesse.
Sister.
The horrible truth about the Bureau.
Hiss is the better option.
Go to the Prime Candidate Program in the containment sector.
I have the key card to get you there.
Salvador wanted me to have it.
Wanted?
Bullshit.
I saw what the Hiss did to Salvador.
What it turned him into.
Okay, Dylan.
I'll go.
I want to see the truth for myself.
But only to look for this light projector.
help me we can end this okay i'm gonna go back to my freaky
chanting now ah we got clearance level six baby isn't that
the highest one we got all of them now listen to all his
stories so worth it yeah i don't know what else i'm hoping
to find here dylan can we talk I'd like to tell you about a
dream I had last night.
Yeah?
Off to a good start.
Oh my god, I had a funny dream too.
Okay.
I'm listening.
I was back in ordinary.
Before all of this happened.
Yeah.
But in the dream, I was alone.
It was just me.
I was the only child.
A girl.
My name was Jesse Dylan Faden.
But then the bureau came and caught me, brought me back
here.
Lock me up.
Have you ever noticed that our names, Jesse, Dylan?
They could be girls' names, boys' names.
Could be anything.
I find that weird.
Sure.
What the hell was that?
Is he trying to mess with me?
Yeah, Dylan can be a girl's name.
I think this is the first time I've been able to clearly
understand what the hiss are saying.
You've always been near you.
You want this to be true.
oh my god bureau alert get out of here
one second no spamming please thank you unless you're a bot
then be gone
dylan's actor does a great job of being unsettling right
freaky freaky
name of the sound yeah we'll keep talking to him he has some
maybe dylan's still in there maybe there's a monkey lines
the hiss isn't chat please
dylan dylan would like to tell you about a dream he had just
now just now this again i was going to be the new director
of this place i helped you get a job here so that we could
be together you were an office assistant you'd make coffee
and deliver the mail and there was always plenty of work to
do and it stayed that way forever and ever so you'd be the
director and I'd be the assistant really nice that's
debatable but here's the strange thing the dream shifted and
none of it was real anymore it was a game we were in a game
and it was a fucking boring game you know look at the camera
couldn't stop playing and then it shifted again or maybe it
was another dream already or maybe i'm just confusing but in
this other dream it was more like a musical I don't think
this is a boring game this is an ordinary song about an
ordinary girl from an ordinary town it's the ordinary story
she worked an ordinary job in an ordinary office something
something something something keep going Dylan We got this.
And that's all I can.
Ordinary girl in an ordinary town.
You know when you can clearly tell that something is like a
stress dream?
I had a dream the other last night that, uh, that I went
viral on Japanese Twitter, but I started getting a bunch of
hate because because someone like quote retweeted one of my
tweets and was.
just like this this vtuber does not respect the art of cow
moji see how she uses it willy-nilly and incorrectly she is
making a mockery of the cow moji and i was like oh no i was
like no please i just like cow moji please not cow I was
like no please I'm an otaku just like you the cow emoji the
cow emoji I got I got got got by the cow moji police
orange peel the picture is orange peel maybe I can learn
more about the hiss from him can we talk what you're I just
had an interesting dream again shit I mean what else can you
do though that's fascinating but let's talk about the hiss
for a change yeah this dream is about the hiss best I'm
gonna get in my dream the hiss had broken free of this
prison this house I'd set it free Dylan no and the president
himself was there to welcome us he was the first one to take
the hiss in spread the word so pluribus or whatever at first
many people thought it was horrifying that he was horrifying
but also I mean yeah because it's a little creepy many
people who heard his words wanted to welcome the hiss in and
slowly more and more of them came around until the whole
world was brought together by the hiss it was wonderful
orange okay thanks for sharing that for the record that will
never happen not as long as I'm alive yeah all right let's
keep trying maybe I'm just here to punish myself Dylan
dreams you'd like to share Dylan I mean P6 I'm glad you You
asked, sister, this dream, like all dreams now, felt very
real.
How did I get his head so bald?
And reality now feels like a dream.
Maybe it's all a dream.
Maybe it's all real.
Dream where my brother endlessly tells me about his dreams.
I was in a dark place.
and there was a dark man there his name was mr door mr door
he told me that there are many worlds side by side on top of
each other some inside of others smitten bald in one world
there was a writer who wrote a story about a cop in another
world the cop was real he himself was in all of them at the
same time endlessly shifting between them i asked him how i
could reach these worlds i wanted to bring the hiss there
but he didn't want to help me he didn't a writer like the
idea what did he know not wild about the idea myself through
time The thundersong distorts you.
Tell me about the rider.
Here we go again.
Once more with feeling.
Let me guess.
You want to tell me about your dream.
You're the one who came in.
Yes.
In fact, I'm having a dream right now.
Oh, God.
We've gone from...
Oh.
I had a dream.
Yeah.
Yesterday to had a dream just now.
In this dream.
I'm standing in the corner watching Jesse and Dylan talk
about this very dream.
he said just now and repeated it again now I'm standing
there and watching and that's all I can do out of body it's
as if I'm trapped there and that's all I have to say about
that dream okay okay Dylan that's good oh is he still in
there or is this the hiss playing mind game Or has he been
so...
I don't know.
Has he been so mind-broken from being in this facility for
so many years?
Prime candidate program in containment.
Do you hear that the Hiss prisoner they captured is the
director's brother?
Brother?
And she brought him here?
She's gonna get us all killed.
What if she's working with the Hiss?
Isn't it strange she showed up?
I'm right here!
Excuse you!
Oh my god.
All these people are my...
She might be... Blink!
Blink!
Oh gosh.
Alright, let's see.
Um...
Containment.
No, no, yeah.
Ah, okay, okay.
We can go from logistics then.
Or...
Yeah, yeah, yeah?
Do I have to go...
If I go from security, then I probably don't have to go...
Oh, no.
I think I opened that up, so I don't have to go...
Yeah, it should be fine.
I didn't want to go through the medical wing.
Yeah.
It's been a rough day for the Bureau.
personnel.
I know these poor guys.
Mm-mm.
Average 9 to 5 experience.
Alrighty.
Uh, let's go through security first.
Don't go that way.
Okay.
Hot horse.
Who else wants a piece?
of me!
Where are you for real?
Where are you?
What the?!
Ouch!
That actually hit me.
A little bit.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Um...
Me.
Me!
I want a piece of you!
Uh...
Oh, here, here, here.
A prime candidate program.
Oh, yeah, I remember saying this before.
All right, access.
Six.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I thought he was about to get up.
Look at that, dog.
Nice reflexes.
Thank you very much.
Oh.
That's not what I...
That's not what I was doing!
I was trying to read it.
Oh, it's... Oh my gosh, it's Salvador!
I didn't even...
It should be... Never have been accessible to low clearance
staff in the first place.
What the dog doing?
Case files?
Oh, we missed some.
the Benikoff a CRT television built by Benikoff and Sun's
electrics the screen is still functional object can levitate
yeah yeah yeah the object was first discovered in a local
news story from Redacted Kansas a figure had been seen
Redacted over buildings floating the Bureau dispatched
agents to the town who discovered that a man named Redacted
had bound himself to the object Mr. Redacted was detained
and the object was brought to the bureau for study mirror
supplement this is the one that I think I just got right
Victorian mirror redacted she was admitted to the mental
ward for emotional instability soon after relocating to
Illinois with her family in 1914 yeah Clark Kent I'm a
Superman over here he's like no please you don't understand
I'm trying to save this town the item only appears on
records again in 2000 on record again in 2006 when the
Bureau investigated a sudden rise in disappearances in
Redacted, Illinois.
Agents found the item hanging in the local library.
They contained it quickly, though the missing people of the
town were never recovered.
August 18th, 1915.
We certify that the case of Mrs. Redacted has shown her to
be a lunatic under the reasons of hysteria, bad company, and
imaginary female trouble.
Dang it!
and my my troubles are fake my troubles are imaginary oh my
god oh my god it's all because I'm a woman and my everything
is in my head imaginary female sorry guys I can't stream
today I'm having imaginary female trouble and I just can't I
can't get over it sorry men you're not allowed to have
troubles that are that are imaginary.
Your troubles can only be real.
A woman moment.
Oh my gosh.
Honestly, it is like a 1915 moment now, isn't it?
That's not... Bad company is also very funny.
Man, she just hated her neighbors.
They were bad company.
Oh man.
I want imaginary problems.
No, my problems are imaginary, and they make me upset, even
though they're not real.
Her fixation with the family looking glass is noteworthy,
though not uncommon matter when considering the female
disposition.
Mrs. Carver is a fit subject for the lunatic asylum and will
remain in its confines until her affliction has passed.
Wait, they didn't censor her name there.
And the refrigerator.
An Arctic Queen brand electric refrigerator from the 1960s.
No cooling functionality?
What's it for then?
Yeah, I guess you just stick a nice block of ice in there,
like an ice box.
The door is decorated with crayon illustrations by Reduct.
The illustrations cannot be removed from the item.
All attempts have failed.
The paper cannot be burned or torn.
the item first came to the bureau's attention after it
survived the collapse of the new york city's grand central
hotel where it served as an appliance and apartment redacted
rented by a man named redacted it became the subject of
local infamy after surviving the building's collapse
undamaged mr redacted who was out of the building at the
time of collapse redacted pm retained ownership of the item
until 1974 when the bureau purchased the item through a
false identity here's a cookie for your imaginary troubles
no no No, no, the cookie is a part of my imaginary troubles.
I had a dream about the cookie and it cheated on me.
In my dream.
And now I'm mad.
Yesterday was my birthday.
I know you probably can't sing MGS Happy Birthday.
Oh, what do you mean that?
I probably can't.
So I want to say thank you for being one of the very few
awesome content creators that mangoes.
yummy happy 27th cat make ball happy birthday happy birthday
congratulations happy birthday may your sky stay blue happy
birthday to you They can't make ball.
Well, we have some hotline stuff.
The former descent is back, not gone.
Now we hate the cookie.
It has been redacted.
It has previous disappointment.
Disappointment is not part of the board.
We apologize.
Deny all knowledge.
For the inconvenience.
You will see, face the former.
It is stealing, linking, altered items.
It builds a competition, not us.
You must espionage, destroy, when possible, inevitable.
Do not believe, get hyped.
About the former's lies, ads.
We provide better bonus package health plan.
If you leave, you will be sorry, dead.
And if you never work exists.
And you will never work exists.
in this torn cosmic reality again.
Yes.
Oda has a cookie cheat on you?
Oatmilk, soy?
Where it was supposed to be a mint chocolate chip cookie and
it became oatmeal.
It was very...
Are you picking up one of my imaginary problems?
We reached Tether through control points into the Bureau
House Nexus threshold area codes.
Allows for access.
You can.
Translocate fast travel construct.
Through the control points.
Yeah, I know.
Why was that unread?
Thanks, I guess.
Every time.
Every stinking time.
To find new prime candidates.
The Bureau needs a director.
Our future.
P6 and P7.
She's all greens, man.
She belongs to the fields.
No!
What was that one?
After North Moore stepped down, I doubled every...
She's seven.
Is that us?
There was no one.
No one but me.
That wasn't good enough.
I pushed hard.
I never wanted the Bureau to end up in that situation again.
The Bureau needs a director.
Always.
When my time reaches an end.
I want more options on the table.
P1 through P5 were all false leads.
Dead ends and disappointments.
then P6 Dylan Faden he fell into our arms no parents they're
gone casualties of an AWE yeah the boy has exceptional
talent the oldest house will be his home we'll build him
from the ground up he'll be trained and taken care of where
was Jesse as their parents were done this project I can't
I'll stay away I will not fail the boy like I failed my own
family my daughter and my wife we were careful enough back
then something came home with me I took work home my Susanna
got sick no when I realized my mistake I wanted to bring her
here for darling flat-out refused civilian doctors treated
our daughter But they didn't have a clue.
Because it was Paranatural!
No!
Kate left me.
And then Kate died.
No!
A long time ago.
The Bureau is all I have now.
Oh my gosh.
And the Prime Candidates are our future.
There are two.
P6 and P7.
We're spoiled for choice.
Hmm.
This place looks crazy.
There really nothing in...
Whoa, Phil!
Thank you!
Sorry, I'm late.
I just woke up from a post-con nap.
Wanted to say thank you!
Thank you and Tencentu for performing in the VX Factor!
Seeing you live during my first ever con was so surreal.
Thank you for fostering such a nice and cute community.
Oh, Bill!
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the walk, I assume.
But I'm so glad you had fun.
And good morning.
Good morning, Minto.
It's so funny because I think like the X-Factor part of it
totally flew over Phoebe and I's head.
I mean, we talked about it.
But like, we were like, oh, because they told us like, Yeah,
just pick, like, kind of...
Pick...
Pick, like, retro songs.
And we were like, okay.
Vicky picked someone who is an actual...
X-Factor winner.
And...
Phoebe chose Seikon Hiko, and I chose Catch You Catch Me
from Cardcapt.
Oh, hold on.
We were like...
Oh, X-Factor.
VX-Factor.
But by the time we already chose, it was like two lays.
It's fine.
Muscle Pirate 5.
Oh, five.
Thank you.
You are a worm through time.
The thunder song distorts you.
Happiness comes.
White pearls.
But yellow and red and eye.
This is what they say.
Through a mirror, inverted is made right.
Leave your...
insides by the door, push the fingers through the surface
into the wet.
Orange peel!
Who did Vicky sing?
I don't remember her name but that song.
Keep burning.
Keep burning love.
That one.
Burn in love.
Yeah.
She said so and I was like, oh.
Oh, what the?
Oh, wow.
Where'd the other one go?
There he is.
Wait!
Oh, shoot.
That's awkward.
What is that?
Wait, what is that?
He's coming this way.
Wait, what was that?
It looked like a big monkey!
Oh.
Ah!
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh, it's not a big monkey, it's a shield.
Oh shoot.
Yeah.
Evasive maneuvers, absolutely.
That's all I got.
What is that down there?
Oh shoot.
Who is it?
What is it?
Oh, I guess it disappears.
huh okay oh we figured it out you could change the shoulder
what was it oh oh middle button also oopsie wait how do I
change the shoulder view I cannot remember oh are oh thank
you thank you what is going on in here I just realized whoa
whoa Oh,
hi, Johnny.
You spooked me.
Hold on.
Let me crisscross my legs.
It'll be easier for you.
Wait, what time is it?
Is it your food time?
No, you have 30 minutes.
Where'd you go?
Oh, come here.
Come here, I'll feed you in 30.
Come on up.
Yeah, there he is.
He's in my lap.
There you go.
Hi, baby.
No, don't eat that.
Hold on, I'm gonna let him lay down first.
Yeah, he's never eaten before ever.
Are you starving?
Are you starving that you would rather eat a wire?
I've had to get him a couple times because he'll...
Oh, he left.
Okay, never mind.
He'll eat wires, like, plugged in, you know.
I'm like, hey.
Oh, okay, he's back.
He's kidding.
You've never had any food before your store ran.
Okay, um, that's not a good way to lay down.
Okay.
All right, we're fine.
What did I get?
I don't know.
Something cool, probably.
Look at the mirror.
Oh, okay, okay.
That's the thing that we accidentally accepted before.
But, whoa!
This area is huge!
Oh my gosh, okay.
How do I get down there?
I mean, obviously I could jump, but...
I guess actually... Oh wait, no, there's over here.
Or we'll go down first.
Wait!
Ouch.
Microplastics, more like electric shocks, right?
Why do I need...
He says, I will harness its power and become stronger.
Anything else around here?
Any cool stuff to read?
What?
Johnny's stupid.
He's acting funny.
Maybe I'll go.
Yo, Johnny Evil?
If I got rid of one, maybe I could.
Okay, I don't see anything up here.
Okay.
I'm gonna have to go feed him, huh?
He's being a little silly guy.
Wait, I missed a collectible?
I did?
Where at?
I'm looking.
I do not see.
Anywhere else?
Oh.
Upstairs far back left.
The one that I open.
Oh, thank you.
Bright Falls!
Hold on.
I will turn on his mic.
Oh, sorry.
Yonned in the mic.
Alice Wake.
Mr. Wake's wife was found during the Bureau of Investing.
investigation.
She was...
Wait, oh, he's climbing me?
Johnny, you wanna go?
No, you wanna get more comfy.
He yawned again?
You're making me laugh.
Oh, he's leaving.
Bye, Johnny!
okay hi johnny she was interviewed and evaluated she showed
signs of severe mental trauma in the form of redacted memory
loss she was later directed to treatment it was concluded
that she had been trapped in the threshold oh my gosh he's
back can you please make up your mind yes can you please
make up your mind it was concluded that she had been trapped
in the threshold during its manifestation i can't play, I'm
sorry.
Notable individuals still missing in the Bright Falls event
are FBI Special Agent Robert Nightingale and Dr. Emil
Hartman referred to the creator's dilemma.
Okay, he's gone again.
Bye.
Oh my gosh.
If I'll read the Cauldron Lake Lodge, Bureau researchers
believe that this event was the result of a forceful
perception of subjective reality stemming from Mr. Wake,
overlapping on our own.
Wake has been flagged as a potential parallel utilitarian
see prime candidate program file for more details in 2011 a
book by clay steward titled the alan wake files was
published by roundabout press new york and olympia agents
agents interviewed clay steward and suspected minor para
utilitarian sensitivity he was placed under indefinite
survey surveillance he's back oh my gosh johnny you want to
sit in my lap here here A monitoring station was established
at Caldron Lake to alert the Bureau of any future activity.
Oh gosh, I'm sorry.
He's climbing on top of me, you guys.
And he's leaving.
I don't think he likes the mic.
Come on, come on.
I won't use it again.
Okay, bye.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm glad.
Thank you so much for telling me about it.
I missed that one.
Sorry, that took like 15 minutes to read because of a cat.
He likes to be held like a baby, so he often climbs, like
you know, he'll like climb up my shoulder, basically.
Because he wants to be held like a little baby.
Alright, what do we got around here?
Oh, something down there.
I will grab it.
Right here.
She is just a little baby.
What did I get?
Launch efficiency?
Hello.
I might have to go feed him.
He's being incessant.
You get fed in 15 minutes, Johnny.
Energy recovery.
Wait, is that better than my current one?
35!
It is!
This one's better.
Okay, cool.
Then we'll...
Deconstruct this one.
Jido-chan likes to be held like a baby too.
Unfortunately, she's 16 pounds of a little baby.
Oh my gosh.
And my launch efficiency.
Okay, this one's gonna be probably the best one that we can
get.
Or launch energy, I mean.
And we have good health stuff.
Yeah.
Health recovery per element pickup.
I think we're okay.
Anything else down here?
Anything?
Not even a...
Not even a file, okay?
Jonathan Akihabara, Jonathan Sasaki Akihabara, contained
yourself.
Alay!
This has to open, right?
Oh, it does.
Okay, wait, before we go in there, though.
Oh, I think this is...
Oh, awesome.
Okay, perfect.
I read the signs, you guys.
I read the signs.
We have...
P6 and P7.
I would...
Go...
We'll start from here.
Hold cases and we'll go down the line.
I think.
The map makes it quite confusing.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, what the hell?
Oh, it's, oh no, the TV show.
The show that's supposedly made for children.
Bright Falls!
Ah, we're getting everything Bright Falls here!
Oh, wait.
September 13th was just a couple days ago.
An unconfirmed threshold manifestation at Caldron Lake
Washington resulted in a fictional story written by the
author, Alan Wake, creating an AWE in which reality was
altered to match that of the story, though only locally and
for a limited time.
Mr. Kirkland, head of investigations, was alerted on
September 13th, 2010.
It's the 20th?
Happy anniversary of this.
By ex-Bureau agent Frank Breaker.
That an AWE event was taking place in Bright Falls,
Washington.
Referred to events investigated in 70, 76, 78.
Breaker had received a call from Barry Wheeler.
Alan Wake's literary agent.
On behalf of Breaker's daughter, Sarah, who is a current
sheriff of Bright Falls.
Sending Johnny some love, too.
Wrapping on my big weekend with my Minto plushies.
Took her to Hamilton into the new Resident Evil movie.
Ending the night with the rest of this bond.
Thank you, Minky.
Melody, thank you!
Oh my gosh, everybody's here.
It's like a...
It's the Avengers of Remedy almost.
Remedy verse.
If we got some more Max Payne, maybe, too.
A bureau field team arrived at the site two days later only
to confirm that the event was over.
Interviews were conducted.
Referred to 1970 redacted Thomas Zane.
76, 78.
Odin Anderson, Tor Anderson!
Alan Wake was believed to redacted instigator.
I-Witness reports highlight an old light switch, possible
object of power that redacted missing.
Wake was not found.
at the scene reports claim he dived into the lake but nobody
was recovered in the search oh yeah and quantum break right
guys come here Johnny is I got to get him a obviously a well
I was gonna get him a vet he's back in my lap by the way I
was gonna get him a vet appointment anyway cuz hey stop
chewing on it the shelter said that he needed a couple more
things to get looked at but he this stinking cat already
scratched his chin like there's a wound on his chin and if
you know anything about cats you know that's so frustrating
and bad because you know when you get a wound it becomes
itchy when healing and cats know don't know not to itch it
and so you know if they scratch it especially with their
like you know their paws that's all they got like a back paw
you know um it they go they're disgusting they go in their
own toilet box so it could get infected oh my gosh i'm like
i've had you like i haven't even had you for a month
to go feed him real quick i'll be right back because he's
he's getting a little he's getting a little antsy so i'll be
right back
sorry about that oh the key dokey not feeding yes sorry ah
push off all righty okay shall we continue sorry about that
i also went party so little extra longer here let's watch
this thing oh
she does kind of look like Uncle Mr. Bounds was wrong.
Uncle Mr. Bounds.
I did bad on my clairvoyance test.
You can't ace every test, Meg.
You see, everyone has different brains.
It's true.
Brains.
Oh no, that's a trigger word.
Some brains can talk to each other.
other.
We call this ESP.
ESP?
Some brains can lift objects like a baseball.
Talk about a fly ball, eh, Meg?
What's it want to say?
Is he gonna... So who cares if you fail your clairvoyance
test?
Maybe your brain can throw baseballs or talk to dead people
or make friends blind oh awesome once we know what your
brains can do we'll know what job to give you and if your
brains are just right you'll get to sit in the big chair a
big chair what's that oh the director's chair Wow, it's
huge.
What if I don't want the big chair?
I think Mr. Bones is...
That's why we're all here.
Use those brains to listen for once.
Or the only chair you'll get in is the one with straps.
Who has made this?
Dr. Darling?
Explains a lot about Dylan, huh?
Goodness gracious.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, okay, these rooms are very small.
Wait, where am I supposed to go then?
I wish things had gone differently and ordinary for us.
Mission won't change things.
Finding the projector will.
coming together in this one case a new object of power
something we have not seen before i mean coming from me
that's that's saying something i the boy dylan faden i
wanted to get off mr bowden's wild ride and the sister as
well by once we catch up with her but the boy the boy so
much potential we're talking north we're talking about we're
interruptions and i don't want to invoke his name but it's
completely different circumstances the flying enemies who
were strapped in the chairs i thought maybe they were the
guys that were like you know they had the the brain things
yes they were strapped to the chair and they had the they
went to the astral plane or whatever and brought back
information yeah the astronauts yeah i thought it was those
we lost a valuable member of our team yes oh Ooh, wait.
Excessive force.
Dylan has so much.
But he's just a kid.
I'll take the blame.
He needs some slack.
I mean, boys will be boys.
He's exceptional and under.
Boys will be boys.
They just kill each other.
They kill people.
Don't worry about it.
Roberts got killed.
It's an unfortunate accident.
That's all.
Marshall needs to realize this.
Seeing that Zupa reminded me of mine, time flies.
Welcome back, Seabor.
We'll make this work.
Oh.
Oh, that's his, uh, that's his little cage.
That's Dylan's cage.
Oh, it do as you're told.
Don't eat them bold, buddy.
it tastes so delicious.
P6 victim autopsy.
Agent killed during redacted involving redacted redacted
codename Dylan Faden codename P6.
Blunt force injuries of the head and neck.
Extensive trauma to the abdominal region.
Lacerations and contusions of the upper and lower torso.
Fracture of the spinal cord between the L1 and L2 vertebrae.
fracture of the third through 10th ribs left and right three
oh blunt force injuries of the of extremities abrasions
lacerations and contusions of the extremities dislocation of
the left and right elbow dislocation of the left and right
knee after examination it was determined that the cause of
death was internal bleeding that occurred when the redacted
was contorted through his redacted Dylan.
Dylan Faden Transcript.
Transcript of Conversation For Review by Dr. Darling.
Note, subject was alone during this outburst.
Dylan Faden.
You again.
I thought I told you to leave me alone.
Why are you showing me this?
I can't do anything.
Can't you see where I am?
Why don't you help me get the fuck out of here?
You always show me things I can't do anything about.
Stop showing me her.
I don't care anymore.
And I don't care about you.
You both left me here to roll.
Fuck off, you bitch!
Oh my god, he's talking to Polaris.
I will dig out my own brains if it means getting rid of you.
I don't want you here.
Get the fucking message.
Subject repeated the phrase fuck off numerous times before
being sedated.
Guys, I was not cursing.
I was reading Dylan's transcript.
Please understand.
P7.
Is this what Dylan wanted me to say?
see oh my god we need to find that projector what the heck
is coffee soap I'm more concerned about that last scene
where'd they get this headshot of me oh that's oh my god
that's a great photo of her dang what is coffee soap why are
they so enthused about it all the times I felt paranoid I
was right the Bureau given me the answers but they just
stood by and watched me shoplifting destination urgent
coffee
soap oh
my god file these what my embarrassing photo of me getting
my purse stolen this what am i
They even, they intervene when the penguins are about to
die.
You couldn't do anything?
Oh my god, National Geographic Lady.
This is, oh, this is literal.
This one's nice, though.
This feels like embarrassing photos from the Christmas
party.
Jesse faded movement tracking Departs How do you say it?
Sayane Arrives in Sydney Not Australia Coffee soap clean
energy Maybe
Why did they only track her from September to October?
They only tracked her for like a month Cheyenne Oh,
Cheyenne.
Oh, I got an outfit.
I got an outfit.
We used to play there all the time.
This is our therapy session!
Other kids as well.
We loved it.
This time, I remember, was different.
found a way in deeper into it like it had shifted we went
inside and that's where we found the slide projector a dump
is a place for lost things things that have been thrown away
did you ever feel that way when you were growing up Jesse
what No.
Yes, but that has nothing to do with...
Was there a slide projector at your home when you were
small?
Those were before your time, I suppose.
But your family did look at photos together, maybe.
In one form or the other?
Maybe.
Hmm.
When was this?
Can you remember?
At parties, barbecues?
How did it make you feel?
parents ever show pictures that embarrassed you all those
photos oh my god let me answer something oh my god did that
make you uncomfortable no that's just stupid come on that
has nothing to do with this nothing the slide projector let
me ask you this as a child did you ever fantasize about
worlds inside pictures inside a painting you know stepping
into a painting into a hidden world away from your parents I
don't I don't think so I don't remember maybe
oh my gosh lady would not let a girl speak transit corridor
south okay cool we're we're getting through it I guess I
don't know oh oh
oh we're fine thought I angered somebody they studied what
happened in ordinary here ordinary a w e dang this was like
such a huge thing they made a whole area oh stupid
Oh, shoot.
Woollolo!
Oh my god, I died!
I was... I was greedy.
That was...
Don't let that be a lesson.
Don't seek out mental health professionals.
Just stick with VTubers.
Well...
Um...
I got greedy woolloloing.
How far back am I?
Oh!
Wait, where am I?
Oh, man.
Well, since I'm here, I'm going to go get my new outfit.
I'm going to go change.
I won't load too hard.
Maybe I should unlock some health.
Maybe I should get some more health, huh?
Man.
Oh.
Yeah, sweats!
We're so comfy, cozy.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
I am gonna unlock more health.
I know I...
It's probably...
I wanted to save up for the multi-launch.
But I'll just get this.
Oh, thank you for the red!
Hello, hello, welcome in, welcome in.
Thank you so much!
Um...
Oh yeah, we're so cozy right now, this is great.
Timeline of events.
To examine the invasion's timeline of events for possible
patterns in his behavior.
Establishing a timeline is difficult at present because of
lack of reliable communications between bureau sectors and
staff.
Dorko, thank you so much for the fog.
Good, dude.
Thank you, thank you.
This is just kind of like questions.
Speech analysis.
If we understand the hiss is a force based on vibration and
resonance, then perhaps their incantation, which is now the
agreed-upon term for their vocalizations, is an effort to
express what resonance using human vocal cords in speech.
Oh, express that resonance using human vocal cords in
speech.
if the incantation were recited in a different language.
No, well, thank you!
No, P7!
The most common word used is want.
Interestingly, every usage of the word is attributed to a
you.
You want to listen.
You want this to be true.
You must want these waves to drag you away.
Are we the you the Hiss are referring to?
Does the Hiss believe humanity, possibly all non-Hiss life,
wants to join it, to be consumed by it?
that its goal it's so pluribus it's crazy have you guys
watched that show yet it ended on like such a cool
cliffhanger so i can't wait for season two the second most
used words are through and time is this possible is this
possibly the hiss stating how they arrived here or an
indication of its age not yet it's pretty good there is
clear intention of the words it's it's It's good.
I will say some scenes drag a little bit.
You want to watch Mitvadoam?
But it is good.
Some scenes drag a little.
The main character is a little frustrated.
but understandably so yeah but I still think it's it ended
really good in the first season hmm I saw Vince Gilligan
panicked when he found out about the Rick and Morty episode
with the same idea I don't know I don't wait I don't know
the Rick and Morty episode but I mean a hive mind is not an
original idea so I don't know.
Wait, maybe I do remember that episode.
I don't remember.
I haven't watched Rick and Morty in a really long time.
I watched all of it on an airplane, by the way.
I don't have Apple TV.
I watched all of it on an airplane.
Yeah.
Anyway.
If you saw the episode, you'll see how one-to-one it is.
Oh, really?
There is no clear intention in the words dismissing the
incantation as nonsense as some of my colleagues recommend
is beyond idiotic.
Okay, let's go do that again.
Oh man.
Wait, this is so frustrating.
I'm gonna have to go through everything again, huh?
Oh, why couldn't I just get to?
Oh, why couldn't I just get to a fast travel point.
That's fine.
It'll be a little bit faster because we won't be searching
for stuff.
Mintem following the wrong objective.
Name it better do it.
What do you mean the wrong objective?
I'm exploring!
I'm doing the right thing!
So, through here
An ambush again.
No ambush?
Okay.
Through here.
Oh.
No guy this time.
Maybe we're okay.
Oh, this is open too!
Awesome!
And this is open!
They studied what happened in ordinary here.
Oh That's the place to start looking stinky Something's
stinking up the room
Oh you you I won't let you get me whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa Oh, oh shit Maybe I should have gotten
the guy
Ouch!
I'm weird!
Hello?
Were you gonna do your job or what?
Excuse you!
You got beans for brains?
Come on!
Wait.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, oh!
It disappeared.
Correspondence.
Work chat!
Dead dog!
He did nothing.
He really just stood there.
He's on lunch break.
I see your creepy teeth delivery and raise you a dead dog.
Yeah, like a straight-up deceased dog.
Had a collar on it and everything.
It'd been rotting in that box since they packed it up.
Go ahead and imagine how it smelled.
So don't go whining to me.
I wish I got to watch a parade of human teeth.
Hello?
What's going on here?
Oh, why is that room like so red?
Somebody's coming through.
I think.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
What's going on in there?
I just want to peek.
Oh yeah, I see him.
Psycho Mantis.
To the city.
To see your teeth parade.
He said someone.
You grow up.
You'll get braces.
They'll lead you through the summer.
To join the teeth parade.
Oh.
Hey.
Charge blast boost.
Willow AWE shipping manifest.
Inventory list of recovered materials.
A hollow sphere, stone-like material.
Vitrified soil.
Redacted pieces of various sizes and colors.
Animal carcass, possibly canine.
Rusted metal bucket.
Leather wallet.
Aged shotgun cartridge.
All materials to go to the investigation sector for further
analysis.
Okay.
all right let's go downstairs i guess and do our best it's
all i can do and if i die i die
i feel so oh my god oh my god
oh oops i preemptively was that what i was hearing We're
both prime candidates.
I'm P7!
Experiments.
Oh, golly.
Oh, my gosh!
Oh,
I forgot I could levitate.
be lagging.
Uh-oh.
Everything okay?
Oh.
Something's over there.
We'll get it.
Let me control.
Let me do this port little area.
I cleanse.
I cleanse!
I think YouTube's being a bit stinky, huh?
It's always so cool when they do this.
Wow!
Woo!
Whoa!
We're going back home.
Of course we are.
It started there, and it's...
Never gone away.
What's this area?
A tiny, tiny room.
Of mold.
My favorite!
Minky monkey.
victory, jump after throw good.
Well, guys.
Where are we, anyway?
Transit corridor.
Okay.
I'll keep playing for a little bit longer.
How much longer, realistically, do you guys think I have of
this game, though?
South.
Where am I going?
Turn table.
What the hell?
Have you watched Inception?
A long time ago.
Oh no!
There's mold here!
Oh.
Ha!
Five-ish hours?
I didn't think I would have finished today, but five hours
is not...
Oh, shoot.
Oh no!
There's one of these guys down there.
someone ordered the extra crispy ghost made oh
my gosh screw you
i didn't realize it was so long that's okay that's why i ask
and this way is oh just like a just like a corridor but i'm
curious what's down here if anything
gotta be something No?
Okay.
DLCs.
How many DLCs are there?
Alright, let's see.
I almost fell down.
That would be so bad.
Hmm.
I'm trying to find my way around, like if I can float.
This stupid thing.
That does get stunned for a second, but do you think I can
make it?
Ah There's got to be a way to rotate these tracks Maybe
there's a control panel.
Oh my god.
Oh Oh shoot Oh, you all alone Friend Oh
I want to see you?
Come here.
Freaky.
Oh, with the bags on their head!
Ooh, that's so creepy.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
I thought.
Um, maybe I don't need to be over here.
Unless?
No.
Oh, probably up there is how I control it, no?
But don't we want to go to ordinary?
Oh, dump site.
What?
Hmm.
Unless, actually, oh, bridge operator.
Why not?
There's gotta be a way to rotate these tracks.
Maybe there's a control panel nearby.
Oh, down there!
Okay, we can go.
Wait,
there's nothing here.
Cool.
Can you just permaflow?
Unfortunately, you cannot.
Ooh, we got...
We got a good personal mod.
What was that?
Energy recovery?
We got evade energy cost minus 22%.
Okay.
I'll think about it.
Oh, shoot.
Get me out of this dang mold.
There's no mold here, right?
A control panel.
No mold, people, please.
Oh, the teeth!
Guess who just had to inspect an inbound delivery of, like,
100 teensy, tiny little boxes?
Me.
That's who.
And you know what was inside each one?
A single human tooth.
Freaking gross.
Oh, no.
Okay, how is this going to go horribly wrong?
It won't rotate.
Something's blocking it.
Oh, come on.
Is it you?
What's blocking it?
Is it that?
All right.
Well, actually, let's, like, float over?
Sure, I can figure out.
Not having to go down there, right?
What could it be?
There's a box there.
Um.
Blind me, though.
Wait.
I missed it.
Oh, is it this?
Oh, I see it.
I got the other ones.
Yay!
Yahoo!
Oh my gosh.
And I'm on the bridge at the same time.
You
look like a mental patient.
You escape.
That's not very nice.
I didn't escape.
They just couldn't keep me captive.
They never had me to begin with.
Duh.
I'm very curious about the...
About this down there.
But I don't want to risk it for the biscuit.
That...
Like, these things are so annoying to deal with.
Ow, I just bit my tongue.
Oh, my...
what was that oh i think it's just that thing down there
okay let's keep going where was i um youtube please oh no
i'm so sorry i mean we can't call it soonish because
oh wrong way because we did find that point and i did turn
the bridge and we are if we find another one maybe
hmm sorry YouTube's being a little stinky though little
stinker just like my cat wait let me I'm also gonna switch
my mission because I can't continue towards the ordinary AW
there's so many missions holy cow oh yeah cleanse the
cleanse the Cleanse and contain the Japanese paper lantern.
Ooh.
We have all the mold stuff, too.
I'm definitely not watching in real time anymore, but at
least the streams stop buffering for me.
That's so weird.
What is that?
Oh.
Ah!
Get away from me!
I have so much.
I'm talking to it like it is Johnny.
Get away!
Who are you?
What do you want?
We took him out so fast though.
That was awesome.
Dude didn't even stand a chance.
Oopsie daisy.
have to stop yelling though.
My throat is killing me.
That hurts.
That hurts, but I can't help it.
I get too excitable.
Whoa!
Generator thing.
Are we
flying?
What was the name of that goosebump story you were telling?
Knight of the Jackalantons or something like that?
I believe?
I believe that's what the one it was.
Dodge efficiency.
I wish I could grab you.
Why won't you let me?
I just want to say my days have been awful lately.
No!
Your streams are among the few things I can feel comfort
with.
Thank you for the hard work you do for growing a community,
I'm going to be a big people.
Oh, my love!
I'm sorry, it hasn't been so good.
I'm glad that you have fun on stream.
Thanks for watching, hanging out.
And I mean that for everybody too.
Oh, awesome.
I was going to say, what did that do?
Wow!
Cool.
Ace Combat.
And thank you for being here.
No, thank you for being here.
Search for the side project.
Oh shoot.
Ahya!
Yeah.
More?
Where?
Oh here.
You.
You!
I don't know who that was.
You had a name.
Sorry buddy.
Sorry.
i don't know who are you oh oops oops
fly high yellow 13.
i might say east combat war oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
airplane wreckage the airplane in question has been brought
in from a private airfield located in the town of redacted
cincinnati it is suspected to be connected to the redacted
awe it is being evaluated for altered status the plane is
currently being stored in the transit corridor in this
containment center brought there through the New York subway
tunnel that's a Catalina flying though is that actually
Reptiti mega doo-doo special access redacted tunnel tunnel
links to urban legend centered on a ghost stations abandoned
tracks and redacted the plane's black box is currently being
evaluated for redacted redacted initial reading have been
taken by a research team, though no altered status has yet
to be detected.
I'm very curious to hear what the black box could say about
this.
Where are we anyway?
Oh, okay, okay.
We missed the other turntable areas, so...
Well, they weren't open, so I guess we couldn't even go to
them, though, so it's not like we missed it on purpose.
It just wasn't available.
Cincinnati is an estate.
That's what I...
I didn't want to say...
I was about to say something and I was like, no, everyone's
going to be like, mint, dot, dot, dot.
You're so stupid.
Oh, of course it is.
Oh.
Or are you trying to surprise me?
Bad.
It's Cincinnati.
Ohio?
The Catalina is most famous for finding the Bismarck during
its only mission and the Japanese Navy at Midway.
Oh!
What?
Wait, okay.
I was right!
Say, I say, say, say, say, say, say, say, say, say, say,
say, say, say, say, say, say, say, say, say, say,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, the first
slide was a room with dirty wallpaper and dolls on a shelf.
there were lots of dolls
Dylan Faden the house was empty no one lived there we played
in there a lot it was our secret playhouse Jesse Faden I
went to school with Neil some kids called him nosebleed Neil
note most likely Neil Hosenberg missing it was mean he had
asthma Tom likely Tom Barlow missing and his gang Freddie
Frederick Bartwell missing.
Hugo, no one by this name was found in public records,
bullied him.
We brought Neil to the dump to play.
Today I learned.
Unconfirmed existence of additional slide.
Designation house.
Beep.
Sounds like bad things happening here.
Or maybe we're fine.
Nope.
I hear things.
I definitely hear a lot going on.
Somebody in here?
No?
Kids are cruel, right?
Oh, Miracle, overnight!
I'm here for 29 years, shining a light in the shadows.
Thank you for staying with us.
Here's our first caller.
Hi.
What am I about to tell you?
If they found out, I don't know what would happen.
If who found out, brother?
The men of the soups, they told me it was an industrial
accident.
But this is something else.
Something nobody talks about.
Ordinary.
This certainly doesn't sound very ordinary, we call it.
No, not ordinary.
Ordinary.
It's a town.
And it wasn't an industrial accident.
I mean, that's what they said.
But that's bullshit.
Whoa, please watch the language, Gawler.
Maybe 2 a.m.
but we're still a fan of the shit.
I'm sorry.
It's just my brother was there.
They said the town was destroyed, but it wasn't.
I went there.
The people are gone, but the town's there.
It's still there.
So the population of an entire town disappears, yet the town
remains.
Tell me, was the phrase, there is no salvation written
anywhere?
I'm not sure.
He doesn't get the joke.
thing happened in Brazil in 23 a village called Horde Verde
more than 600 people just up and left the government said
they were fleeing guerrilla forces but we know the truth a
mass abduction I hear they so noisy over there my goodness
is it one of those balls now I warned you about the language
caller I'm afraid we're gonna have to cut you off and good
timing too it's time for a short Hang in there.
America overnight.
We'll be right back.
Ordinary Summary An AWE occurred in the town of Ordinary,
caused by an object of power.
Slide Projector.
Discovered by local children at the dump...
Oh, wait, I wonder if there's a projector then, maybe.
Discovered by local children at the dump outside of town.
When a specific set of slides are used in the projector, the
projected images open doorways to other dimensions.
Multiple slides were used by the children, resulting in the
disappearance of the town's adult population.
On August 30th, 2022, siblings Dylan Faden, 10 years old,
and Jesse Faden, 11, were playing at the local dump when
they found a discarded slide projector.
See, OOP 15.
A team led by Director Trench and Dr. Darling arrived at the
site on September 14th.
Oh my gosh, that was just a couple days ago!
Happy anniversary to ordinary incident.
The AWE had ended, but the team found the Faden children.
who led them to the slide projector and the slides which
have been burned with the exception of one jesse escaped
when agents attempted to detain the pair in total 17
surviving individuals were found in the town all of them
were brought in for questioning and tests and then the prime
candidate stuff
there is a curious correlation with the yet undoable forces
intruding upon our world in the form of altered world events
these forces gravitate toward archetypal objects a gun a
television happy birthday to trauma humanity affects this
process our collective unconscious is a map of sorts we hold
the key but we don't know how to use it we create these
archetypes it's starting to get super hungry popular culture
urban legends but we are observing and influencing a
complicated system in action we can change the likelihood of
something being a receptacle for these forces just by
thinking about it but we haven't found a method to control
the outcome what's for dinner maybe pizza there's something
unique in us in our dreams in the conceptual reality with
power with our minds what's the cause and what's the effect
are we the starting point or just a necessary evil in this
Oh, he liked that one.
Thank you, Dr. Darling.
I can't wait to meet this guy.
When?
When will I meet him?
Ordinary, AWA Stage 4A Town Proper Witness Testimonies.
Jesse and me followed the Dung Monkeys to the cave.
What the heck is that?
There was a lot of them.
More of the kids from town had joined up.
scary.
Jesse grabbed the projector and we ran as fast as we could.
They chased us.
I fell and hurt my knee.
Jesse tried to help me, but the dung monkeys were coming.
What is a dung monkey?
They were just about to get us, but then Neil showed up.
Neil looked like a dog.
Like a melted dog, but I knew it was him.
Neil said a lot of times he didn't like being a boy because
Tom just beat him up.
I think he liked being a dog.
Dylan interview the projector wouldn't turn off so he
changed the slide to the hand I heard her immediately she
promised to help Jesse Jesse said we should call her Polaris
it's because she was doing stars at school Dylan exploited
information additional slide designation hand is verified
and in bureau possession unconfirmed existence of
perinatural entity designation dog Neil What?
No, we don't get to see a dog deal.
No.
What is this?
It's freaking me out.
Oh, it's a tree.
I thought it was some legs.
What the...
Is that the house?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
I got him.
Oh, jeez, Louise.
Awesome.
Hi, friend!
Oh, sorry.
Whoa.
Thought I saw something flash.
Alrighty.
This is what we needed.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
All right, I know there's some stuff over here.
We'll listen to it next time.
I'm so curious about this house though.
And the projector, we're so close.
Okay, I won't go, I won't go, I won't go.
This is my favorite section of the base game.
Really?
Which means you have a favorite section of the DLC.
Oh, and there's something here as well.
Okay, I have to remember that.
What's down here?
Is it a recreation of ordinary?
Like, what?
It's an exciting cliffhanger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll continue in a couple days as well, so.
Next stream is going to go hard.
Oh, I'm so excited!
I'm so excited!
Okay.
I'm going to go get food then.
too you guys should eat something delicious nutritious yeah
it doesn't have to be nutritious whatever you want to eat
and yeah thank you guys so so so much and have a good dinner
you too have a good day have a good night have a good time
zone i will haunt you later otu mito everybody otu otu otu
mito fake me thank you
if your throat feels better soon.
Also, I talked to the board and they said, Director Minto,
have yummy, tasty dinner, good night, sweet dreams,
tickle-toe, potato, squail.
Last part's odd.
Yay, overall, good night.
Good night.
Thank you.
What's up, Minto?
It's up, it's up, it's up.
Right now, thanks for the heart, though.
Thanks to the stream, Minto, for two years.
Thank you.
Thank you, Chippers, for two years.
Thank you so much.
It's up, it's up.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.